TIME FOR THE UNITER IN CHIEF.
THAT IS TWO NIGHTS ANGLE.
OVER THE WEEKEND,
PRESIDENT TRUMP VISITED FIRE
RAVAGED CALIFORNIA ACCOMPANIED
BY DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN AND GOVERNOR-ELECT GAVIN
NEWSOM.
THE PRESIDENT WAS CLEARLY MOVED
BY THE EXTENT OF THE DEVASTATIO
DEVASTATION.
>> NOBODY WOULD'VE EVER THOUGHT
THIS COULD HAVE HAPPENED.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS BEHIND
YOU.
WE ARE ALL BEHIND EACH OTHER.
I THINK WE CAN SAY TRULY, JERRY,
RIGHT?
GARY AND I HAVE BEEN SPEAKING
AND GAVIN AND I HAVE GOTTEN TO
KNOW EACH OTHER AND WERE ALL
GOING TO WORK TOGETHER AND WE
WILL DO A REAL JOB.
THIS IS VERY SAD TO SEE.
AS FAR AS THE LIGHTS ARE
CONCERNED, NOBODY KNOWS QUITE
YET.
THEY ARE UP TO A CERTAIN NUMBER.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
UNACCOUNTED FOR.
I THINK WE ARE ALL IN THE SAME
PATH.
>> Laura: IT WAS UNEXPECTED
WAS HOW GOVERNOR BROWN AND
GOVERNOR-ELECT NEWSOM RESPONDED
TO THEIR DAY WITH THE PRESIDENT.
OF COURSE HIS PERSONAL INTEREST
IN THE TRAGEDY.
>> I APPRECIATE THE PRESIDENT
BEING HERE AND PUTTING THE FOCUS
ON SPOTLIGHT ON PROBABLY THE
WORST TRAGEDY CALIFORNIA HAS
EVER SEEN.
>> THERE IS NO POLITICS BEING
PLAYED HERE.
THE EXPECTATION GOING FORWARD
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS NOT
GOING TO JUST BE HERE TODAY WITH
ALL OF YOU BUT TOMORROW AND OVER
THE COURSE OF THE NEXT FEW YEARS
AS WE REBUILD.
>> Laura: CYNICS ARE GOING TO
SAY IT'S A SHOW BECAUSE BROWN
AND NEWSOM KNOW THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO NEED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S HELP TO RECOVER
FROM THE WORST FIRES IN THE
STATE'S HISTORY BUT STILL, IT
WAS NICE TO SEE.
IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS,
NOTWITHSTANDING SOME ILL-ADVISED
TWEETS ABOUT ADAM SCHIFF'S NAME
AND RETIRED NAVY ADMIRAL WILLIAM
MCRAVEN, TRUMP SEEMS TO BE
PROJECTING A DIFFERENT
DIMENSION.
UNDERSTANDING HE HAS THE
DEMOCRAT HOUSE THAT HE HAS TO
CONTEND WITH, MIGHT
PRESIDENT TRUMP BE TRYING A NEW
APPROACH TO GOVERNING?
SHOULD HE?
WITH THIS CHANGE MINDS ARE GROW
SUPPORT FOR HIS ECONOMIC AGENDA?
IT'S CLEARLY WORKING.
BUT BEYOND ALL THAT, WOULDN'T IT
BE GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY?
I GET THE SENSE MAY BE YOU DO TO
THAT AMERICANS HAVE UNDOUBTEDLY
GROWN WEARY OF HOW POLITICS HAS
INFECTED SO MUCH OF OUR DAILY
LIVES.
NOT THAT IT'S NOT IMPORTANT.
OBVIOUSLY HE IS OR I WOULDN'T BE
DOING THIS EVERY NIGHT.
BUT IT'S NOT EVERYTHING.
AND IT SHOULDN'T BE A
BLOOD SPORT EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T NEED TO
SWING AT EVERY PITCH.
NOR DOES HE NEED TO RESPOND TO
EVERY UNFAIR CRITICISM, NO
MATTER HOW VILE IT IS.
EVEN FROM SELF ABSORBED MEDIA
FIGURES.
THIS THURSDAY IS SUPPOSED TO BE
A TIME WHEN WE ALL GATHER AROUND
THE TABLE TO GIVE THANKS.
NOT TO GET STUFFING THROWN AT US
BY COUSIN HELEN OR UNCLE JOE WHO
IS IN A WHITE RAGE ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S VIEWS ON CLIMATE
CHANGE OR SOMETHING.
MAYBE, JUST MAY BE THAT
PRESIDENT HAS DECIDED TO
MODESTLY RECALIBRATE HIS
APPROACH TO HIS JOB AND FIND
PLACES WHERE BOTH PARTIES CAN
AGREE.
EVEN AS THE CRITICS PERSIST.
BELIEVE ME, I AM NOT SAYING HE
SHOULD CHANGE HIS GOALS ON CORE
ISSUES LIKE TRADE OR
IMMIGRATION.
HE IS DOING GREAT ON BOTH.
BUT HE COULD BE CHANGING HOW HE
PURSUES THEM.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT NEEDS MORE
HAPPY, NOT MORE ANXIOUS VOTERS
GOING INTO 2020.
A RECENT POLL SHOWED 64% OF
VOTERS BELIEVE THE MEDIA HAVE
DIVIDED THE COUNTRY WHILE 56%,
NOT INSIGNIFICANT, BLAME THE
PRESIDENT.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT NEARLY
TWO-THIRDS OF AMERICANS BLAME
THE PRESS, GIVEN HOW BIASED AND
HOW COMPLETELY UNBALANCED MOST
OF THEM ARE AND THEY HAVE BEEN
TOWARDS THIS PRESIDENT SINCE THE
BEGINNING.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS RATCHETING
UP HIS ANTI-IMMIGRATION RHETORIC
USING THE WHITE HOUSE PODIUM TO
STOKE FEARS.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THIS
PRESIDENT IS ANTI-SEMITE OR NOT.
I GET ASKED THAT A LOT.
>> HE GOES ON TELEVISION AND
PRONOUNCES HIMSELF A NATIONALIS
NATIONALIST.
NATIONALIST, THAT WORD HAS BEEN
USED IN MANY WAYS.
IT WAS USED BY THE AMERICAN NAZI
PARTY.
>> Laura: THE VITRIOL FROM THE
HARD LEFT IN THE MEDIA AND YEAH
THERE IS SOME OVERLAP, IS SPEWED
EVEN AS PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
ATTEMPTED BIPARTISAN OUTREACH ON
ISSUES SUCH AS IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
REMEMBER THE DEMOCRATS REJECTED
IT LAST FEBRUARY.
OTHERS MIGHT HAVE RESPONDED TO T
OTHERS MIGHT HAVE RESPONDED TO O
THE POLITICAL STONEWALLING BY
THE DEMOCRATS WITH A "TWO -
TRUMP IS UNDETERRED, TRYING TO
FIND COMMON GROUND, ANNOUNCING
HIS SUPPORT OF AN ISSUE
DEMOCRATS ONCE HEARTILY CLAMORED
FOR.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
>> AMERICANS FROM ACROSS THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM CAN UNITE
AROUND PRISON REFORM LEGISLATION
THAT WILL REDUCE CRIME WHILE
GIVING OUR FELLOW CITIZENS A
CHANCE AT REDEMPTION, SO IF
SOMETHING HAPPENS AND THEY MAKE
A MISTAKE, THEY GET A SECOND
CHANCE AT LIFE.
>> Laura: THIS GOT ABOUT AS
MUCH COVERAGE AS HIS VISIT TO
CALIFORNIA.
NOT THAT MUCH.
NOT ONCE AN DEMOCRAT ATTENDED
THE WHITE HOUSE ANNOUNCEMENT
WHICH I FOUND TO BE A DISGRACE.
THIS POLITICAL SLIGHT WAS NOT
LOST ON SENATOR CORY BOOKER'S
HOME PAPER.
THE STAR-LEDGER WROTE "VOLKER,
WHO HAS MADE A HUGE ISSUE ABOUT
JUSTICE REFORM, SHOULD HAVE
GONE TO THE WHITE HOUSE AND
SHOWED BIPARTISANSHIP.
DEMOCRATS CAN ENGAGE WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE AND SHOW
INDEPENDENCE AT THE SAME TIME."
APPARENTLY NOT.
THE LEFT'S NEW STRATEGY IS TO
COMPLETE LEAD AND I TRUMP HAS
ACCOMPLISHED ANYTHING POSITIVE
AND DENY HIM ANY COOPERATION EVE
AND DENY HIM ANY COOPERATION EVN
AND DENY HIM ANY COOPERATION EVO
AND DENY HIM ANY COOPERATION EVI
AND DENY HIM ANY COOPERATION EVS
AND DENY HIM ANY COOPERATION EVE
AND DENY HIM ANY COOPERATION EVW
THEY AGREE.
HOW SICK IS THAT?
ONLY A FEW FAIR-MINDED LIBERALS
LIKE CNN'S VAN JONES WHO WORKED
WITH THE WHITE HOUSE, INCLUDING
JARED KUSHNER, ON THIS BILL,
ACTUALLY CELEBRATED THE
ACCOMPLISHMENT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID IF THIS
IS GOING TO MAKE STREETS SAFER,
A FAIR CHANCE, SOME OF THESE
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN, LET'S
DO SOMETHING.
I THINK YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE HIM
SOME CREDIT.
I WILL GIVE HIM A SALUTE AND
APPLAUSE.
>> Laura: FOR THAT STATEMENT
OF SUPPORT, JONES WAS LACERATED.
PROFESSOR CRYSTAL MARIE FLEMING
TWEETED "GIVE THE WHITE
SUPREMACIST MISOGYNIST HIS DUE,
VAN JONES SAYS."
MICHAEL HARRIET SAYING NO,
VAN JONES, I DO NOT HAVE TO GIVE
THE RACIST IN CHIEF HIS DUE.
SO MUCH FOR COMMON CAUSE.
BY THE WAY, FOR ALL YOU LOOKING
TO THE OBAMA PRESIDENCY TO THESE
ROSE-COLORED GLASSES TODAY, THIS
IS WHAT THE COUNTRY FELT ABOUT
THE STATE OF AMERICA SIX YEARS
INTO OBAMA'S PRESIDENCY.
55% SAID OBAMA HAD DONE MORE TO
DIVIDE THEN UNITE THE COUNTRY.
WELL, NOW THIS IS SOMETHING THE
PRESIDENT AT THE TIME SAID HE
HAD TO ADMIT WHEN HE GAVE HIS
FINAL STATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESS.
>> IT'S ONE OF THE FEW REGRETS
OF MY PRESIDENCY.
THAT THE RANCOR, THE SUSPICION
BETWEEN THE PARTIES HAS GOTTEN
WORSE INSTEAD OF BETTER.
>> Laura: ARE THINGS TODAY
WORSE?
MAYBE.
FOLKS FROM BOTH PARTIES, THEY
COULD DO BETTER, INCLUDING THE
PRESIDENT.
INCLUDING ME, ALL OF US, I
GUESS.
WE SHOULD CELEBRATE THE
PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE IS TRYING
TO REACH ACROSS THE AISLE.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM IS JUST
ONE OF THE EXAMPLES.
JUST BECAUSE HATERS ON THE LEFT
ARE GOING TO RIDICULE HIM OR
BELITTLE THE PRESIDENT'S
EFFORTS, IT'S NO REASON FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO BACK OFF.
HIS TRIP TO CALIFORNIA, PRISON
REFORM, HIS WORK TO LIFT THE
STANDARD OF LIVING OF MINORITY
COMMUNITIES, IT'S ALL POSITIVE
SIGNS.
THERE ARE THOSE WHO WILL WORK
OVERTIME TO DEFLECT AND DEMEAN
ANY EFFORTS BY THIS PRESIDENT TO
BROADEN HIS APPEAL.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, TO BROADEN THE
APPEAL OF HIS POLICIES THAT,
AGAIN, ARE WORKING.
I SAY LET THE CRITICS DO WHAT
THE CRITICS ARE GOING TO DO.
THIS WILL MAKE THEM LOOK PETTY
AND JUST PURE PARTISAN.
REAGAN APPEALED TO WOMEN AND
MINORITIES BY SMILING THROUGH
THE STORM.
ALWAYS KEEPING THE FOCUS ON THE
LIVES OF EVERYDAY AMERICANS.
TRUMP CALLS THEM THE FORGOTTEN
PEOPLE.
THEIR FAMILIES, THEIR JOBS,
THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS, THEIR FAIT
FAITH.
BY TAKING THE FOCUS OFF HIMSELF
AND KEEPING IT ON THE HORIZON OF
POSSIBILITY, THE PRESIDENT WILL
UNMASK THE REAL DIVIDERS AND